how's everybody doing it's 2:30 yeah
feeling okay that's one person okay so
looking forward to getting this started
my name's Dan law I am NOT an energy guy
I'm actually a startup guy so I just
wanted to thank Carnegie Mellon and Anna
and the Scott Institute folks for
letting me be here and offering a couple
remarks about what we do around
innovation so we're not energy folks at
all in fact we're not trying to pick
winners we're what we call a start build
hub we're over in East Liberty and we're
called ascender and as a 501 C 3
non-profit we like to talk about things
like innovation ecosystems and high
growth vertical software-as-a-service
platforms and all that kind of stuff but
and we like to talk about energy too but
one thing that we've been noticing a lot
is that behind all of these terms and
buzzwords are a very human story in all
of our ecosystems and all of our
problems and all of our challenges are
really made up of individuals and human
beings and that's what we like to
celebrate and so you know without diving
too far into it I think the investment
component of these stories is really
really important and it really informs
in some respects the future of what
we're going to be as a region and
interestingly enough everybody on the
panel here none of you are from
Pittsburgh right one Bruce Marty you
went to CMU maybe so we're bringing
folks here from Vancouver Chicago New
York Berkeley I think outside New York
City that's pretty exciting and that's
pretty cool stuff so without further ado
Bruce you're gonna be moderating today
he is the partner and pathfinder of
Capital Advisors Eric Burkhart how are
you the chief executive officer of Clean
Energy Trust
look my fingers here Matt Myers vice
president of Earth X Marty which already
called you chief executive officer of a
VOC innovations Johanna Wolfson
principal of prime impact fund as I just
strap myself
it's a millennial moment so first off
I'd like to thank everybody for being
here Bruce I'm gonna hand it over to you
and I'm looking forward to the
discussion on the investor's perspective
trends and insights and energy
innovation
okay there we go
again I'm Bruce gave our Pathfinder
capital advisor for what it's worth
Pittsburgh native recently come back and
got involved with various companies have
gone done a lot of energy work both as
placing investors as a broker dealer as
well as doing seed investment for some
local clean tech companies and other
things and I'm deeply appreciative of
the fact that that Anna and others
invited me and also concur with the rest
of my panel that we talked about earlier
we're glad to be here
so what we'd like to do is just have a
informative discussion as best we can as
to where we see the market perhaps
you're an entrepreneur looking it at how
to fund things what to do and we'd like
to give you some insights to that since
I'm at Carnegie Mellon I'll sort of make
a robotics comment that somebody had
once been quoted as saying that the jobs
likely to be automated or substitute it
with robotics or the three out of the
four DS dirty dull dangerous and
demeaning so therefore we will try not
to be any of those because we don't want
to be a substitute with with the robot
by by next year and so let me throw it
open to the panelists that in a world
where venture capitals are more easily
to fund an app that you know sort of
makes you look like a cap or something
else that we're some kind of social
network type of thing and clean tech
involves you know physical items areas
that are a little bit harder to do how
and why did you decide to participate in
the energy space start with Eric and
work our way down if that's okay it's
great to be here and I've actually my
first time on Carnegie Mellon's campus
and quite impressed hope to come back
later this year and spent a few days
here because there's definitely just a
wealth of assets here that I'd like to
learn more about but so you know I
became involved sort of in clean tech
and energy by beginning my career in
industrial products right at a time when
it became apparent that rather than sort
of trying to sell these products on
feeds and speeds that you could really
construct a pretty compelling financial
argument around energy savings so I got
pulled into clean tech in energy
efficiency and demand-side management
basically by you know figuring out a new
approach to selling products such as
pumps and lighting systems and so forth
but you know fast-forward today you know
what keeps me in it and what what the
reason I'm now doing what I'm doing is
you know previously my career I was
always working for you know trying to
make a single company successful and now
in my role at cleaner to trust to have
the opportunity to really work and try
to make a whole sector successful and
help many different companies kind of
break through and succeed and that and
that's really what gets me going and
keeps me you know active and out of debt
each morning
so the question is how we wound up in in
investing and clean tech so my pathway
here was really from that of a lab
scientist trained as a physical chemist
in materials and I was really passionate
about solving energy challenges in the
lab and when I was in graduate school at
MIT I felt like I was surrounded by
incredible science and really sci-fi
stuff that could change the world and
the more I learned about the path
afterwards I realized there's no pathway
out or that the pathway out is really
broken and that's when I started
learning about all of the mechanics
around investing and manufacturing and
all of them really all of the hard stuff
that follows an invention in the lab and
learning about how the by-and-large the
startup support system and financing
system that we have is optimized for
capital light software like technology
so I became really passionate about
about working on those challenges
specifically for Hardware intensive
technologies hello there we go so Marty
read my path shortly after graduating
Carnegie Mellon I moved out to Silicon
Valley and was a classic tech
entrepreneur I did five startups and
went through kind of that personal
decision point in my life where I said
enough developing apps for for
kitty-cats and I really wanted to
dedicate myself to issues around climate
change and when I made the decision to
switch over to venture capital had the
good fortune to partner with a few folks
in Berkeley who are like-minded and so
for that point on really drove down the
path of making investments around that
that sort of climate thesis and now just
recently I guess now two years ago made
the decision to move to Vancouver call
me a trump refugee I guess but we
launched evoke with a
a different focus which was or a more
specific focus I guess which was instead
of trying to transform the energy sector
from Berkeley and no offense to Berkeley
but I've now partnered with some of the
world's largest oil and gas companies
and I'm helping them drive towards a
zero carbon future and so our model is
now somewhat akin to what what Dave was
talking about with breakthrough ventures
in our case just specific to that one
thesis around industrial processes so
that's my background
hi I'm Beth solder from cyclotron Road
my my foray into this area I think
started in in college I guess when I you
know at that time I feel like the the
emphasis on achieving environmental
goals is really about regulation and at
as I went through grad school it started
to shift to to the idea that you can
make money while doing good things for
the environment and it and I realized
that the misalignment between the or
should I say the the fact that the
people working on the science weren't
necessarily always really wherever
well-versed in what the economics of
what they were doing and the impacts
that they were having made me start
looking actually very closely in
graduate school at looking at the
intersection of science and economics
and in particular looking at technical
economic models of how new technologies
and emerging technologies might perform
in the marketplace and in particular I
was very interested in bioenergy energy
crops at that at that time or starting
to become involved there's a lot of
research being done on that and the
question I had was well if we have this
resource what's the most cost effective
way to use it to to mitigate carbon
emissions there's multiple technologies
right you have biofuels you
can have gasification combined cycle you
can have Co fire with coal
well which one of those makes the most
sense and you can't do that
it basically what it came down to was
what's the the cheapest way to avoid a
ton of carbon right with this resource
and so I really got into doing - looking
at some of the NRL's techno-economic
models and realizing that this was
really important that people who are
working on the technology really need to
understand at a fundamental level the
key drivers of what's gonna make
something competitive or not especially
as a commodity from there I then went to
work at a biofuels company it's like put
your money where your mouth is um and
did directed an R&D program there on
trying to reduce the cost of actually
macro algae or seaweeds a feedstock I
know a lot about seaweed and then
finally and now I'm working at a
cyclotron Tureaud which is a program
hosted at Lawrence Berkeley National Lab
were funded by advanced manufacturing
office of the midea we on the California
Energy Commission and also DARPA to help
early-stage innovators but advanced
their technologies from lab to market
and one of the things I focus on there
is helping people in developing a
curriculum around how to teach
scientists and engineers coming out of
those programs to understand the
fundamental economics of their
technologies and the markets and so
building you know we listened earlier
today breakthrough energy ventures even
in the battery form you hear talking
about techno economic modeling and so
that's I think a really important
connection between the science that our
people are doing the lab and the
investors that want to invest in their
technologies but need to understand what
needs to happen to make that to make
that work so I'm excited to be in that
in that space and continuing to work
there
see I got oh I'm alive
Matt Myers earth X my path is a has been
a winding one I would say that I was
first inspired because I lived in China
for six and a half years was doing my
graduate degree out there at Chino
University doing my MPA and
International Development and was
studying climate change and our
professor brought in one of the top
negotiators for for China and he showed
the demand for for steel and cement from
2012 to 2020
and it just kept skyrocketing and they
said oh yeah it's gonna it's gonna peak
around 2020 in them it'll level out and
start declining gradually and I as you
all most people in this room who I know
those are the true the most energy
intensive industries out there and I
looked out the window and I could barely
see a tree that was eight feet ten feet
away from me because the amount of
pollution in the air I actually couldn't
eat locally for the last year and a half
that I that I lived there I was eating
canned peaches and imported beef from
Australia and yogurt from Germany
because my gastrointestinal system
couldn't take it anymore and so for me
it was physically experiencing what
what's happening with the environment
the impact it was having on society and
the impact it was having on myself and
then also looking at the data and
thinking oh geez we are we're screwed if
we don't do a couple things one have
policy that puts a price on carbon and
negative externalities which is probably
not going to happen United States and
the other would be deploying a huge
amount of capital towards solutions that
are going to save the planet I didn't
get a chance to work on that for a
little while as paths are winding
met our founder earth exiled or trammel
escrow philanthropist environmentalists
are green Republican in 2009 in Shanghai
moved back long story told short founded
a clean tech Investment Summit called a
capital summit now it's almost two years
and from a blank screen to what it is
now and at the core of it we are working
to get conservative Texans to take a
look at the space especially high net
worth individuals and families and
hopefully start deploying in that area
let me tell you it is a it's a tough job
but from what I learned this the
Appalachian region has a similar
political culture and makeup and I am
delighted to say that I feel now after
two years that we are starting to make
progress because people are
understanding that that clean tech is
really increasing efficiency across many
different industries and there is a
economic case to be had so that is my my
story I guess okay thank you I
appreciate everyone's thoughts on that
it's just an interesting note how in
each case you know your personal
observations and what you had affect you
you know really does have an impact as
to what you do for the rest of your life
just real quickly on my side I'm
probably a little older than the average
panelist here remember as a kid sort of
staying you know being in a line during
the Arab oil embargo you know trying to
get gasoline and I read a couple books
of energy future and limits to growth
and a couple other different things and
back then people thought there was sort
of an ironclad relationship between GDP
and energy use I mean you could read it
in books again it again it made no sense
to me
so when I became an engineer and I
started looking at it I said there's so
much inefficiency in every one in every
system and it still continues to this
day it's amazing and the other thing
that always fascinated me about energy
is the tentacles are everywhere I mean
it affects literally we would not be
able to talk to you on microphones we
would be a dark room there's
socio-political economic you name it
it's affected really energy is kind of
the Nexus of life so to speak you you
can't get around it through it or
whatever and it certainly does make life
an awful lot easier for those people
that have it so let me move on to the
next question
or I mean all of you could be regarded
as as being involved in sort of social
impact investing ie getting something
more than just your dollar affecting
society with your investment and some
people would call it the Golden Age of
impact investing is that the Golden Age
is the kind of last or is it a fan run
with it go ahead I'll leap in just
quickly I think the phrase Golden Age
may be a little bit aggressive because I
think we're really only at the front end
you know if you just consider that
trillions of dollars if through the
capital markets I mean they're so it's
it's almost a rounding error in terms of
the type of you know investment that's
going into you know the impact category
so I think it's just at the very very
front end and you know Prime Coalition
is doing great work trying to figure out
how to get foundations you know into the
marketplace you know that describes
trying to get high net worth individuals
in the marketplace I mean we're only
we're only at the very very very
beginning first steps so yeah I would
agree with that I don't think it's a fad
I think it's a trend that is that it
will continue to grow I think it's very
it's a very imprecise term
so I always when I get asked about
impact investing I always try to
understand what someone means by that
and there can be there are there shades
of what that means and I think some of
those shades are represented on this
panel which is great so sometimes that
can mean profit seeking capital seeking
impact alongside it so there's there's
absolutely no concession in terms of
what's being sought sometimes there is
what's called concessionary capital
that's looking to take that that's all
right with taking some some lower return
or accepting some lower return or taking
higher risk with some trade-off for
impact where Prime is on that is we are
unabashedly impact first but we're only
able to do that because we're using
charitable philanthropic capital and we
it probably would not be appropriate for
most venture funds to take that approach
so I think there's a whole continuum and
it's useful to describe it because I
think that as we see that trend evolve
it'll kind of move if from one end which
is more kind of double bottom-line focus
yes we're in it for impact but we're
also in it we're not surrendering any
returns I think that's where we're
seeing the trends start and it will I
think continue to evolve along that
spectrum is my guess I'll jump in and my
my perspective on this having been
through a cycle or so 2007 was the
golden age of course we were completely
clueless and lost all of our money so be
careful what you wish for and so from
that peak in oh seven through now we're
still down 90 plus percent and cleantech
as a percentage of venture capital which
is you know my particular focus within
the capital stack still is only about 2%
of the overall capital going in I do
however have reason for optimism in in
there is now been an emergence of some
some new models obviously we talked
about breakthrough energy ventures OGC I
is an example in the energy sector which
is a consortium
ten you know global energy companies who
put in a billion dollars you know to
provoke you know I think what we created
evoke is an interesting approach where
we take some some of the attributes of
traditional financial venture
investments with strategic investing and
now you're also starting to see some
models that are supporting those
companies that we screwed up in 2007 and
the physical sciences through smarter
incubator programs like cyclotron Road
which I love and we've invested in
several cyclotron Road companies and if
you're in the physical sciences space
and trying to commercialize I can't
recommend a program higher and I hope
they replicate this I know they're
starting to replicate at National Labs
but I hope that universities are
starting to look at that also I think
it's a fantastic model
so so I'll just add to that I think that
one of the issues with with impact
investing is how do you have a sort of
an objective quantifiable screen for
what that impact is and it's very
difficult if you're an investor to all
of a sudden understand but how you can
condense all the nuance metrics that
could go into something like impact
which as a word is Serena pointed out is
incredibly vague and can can capture a
lot of different things I think one of
the things that that cyclotron Road does
is it is it provides a very highly
vetted filter AM screen for for
technical merit and not just technical
merit but also we screen forthe sort of
the personality characteristics that we
look for in our innovators that we think
will lead to successful outcomes yeah I
think that's a important point and I
know prime actually has written a paper
on this but the question you know the
impact in how you define it and how you
measure it is basically nobody's cracked
the code on that there's not a
consistent framework there's not a
consistent methodology being pursued and
part of the issue is if you look at a
framework you know that's used let's say
at a fortune 500 company like iris right
that's a retroactive look that's
basically telling you what's happened
but you know we're all dealing with
technologies that are coming out of the
lab they're nowhere near scale they're
not near the market or maybe they're
just entering the market you really to
measure what their potential impact will
be kind of on a forward-looking basis is
incredibly difficult and the danger I
think is that there'll be a propagation
of different approaches and
methodologies and suddenly people will
get concerned because they don't know
who to trust and it may actually scare
capital away from the space particularly
those people who are approaching
with an impact lens yeah I I agree and I
I do a lot of work in a conservative
part of the country and I've had to
shift and it's ROI first impact second
now impact what does that mean yeah you
want to have a positive impact on
society on the planet who doesn't but at
the end of the day it's it's also about
ROI people want to make a return on
their investment and it's something that
I'm talking about now with some folks is
that everybody is admitting that the
climate is changing
they just can't say climate change even
Scott Pruett is saying but the climate
is changing okay we all we all know it
it's baked in the data is there so why
aren't we moving faster and I think this
is the biggest arbitrage in human
history for for what's gonna take place
over the coming years because if we
don't change the planet's gonna force
governments to change and that's gonna
lead to a huge amount of capital flow
deal flow towards these industries so
for me that's the way I've I've started
to paint it especially the past months
let me kind of add the Wall Street
perspective right so again we we have a
broker-dealer so not only we've done
seed investment but we also have talked
with fairly large substantial and not
every one of the problems I find is some
of these people frankly are not as
educated shall we say in the
technologies or understanding it or even
assessing the probability of success and
so you've got different slices and you
don't all have everyone doesn't have a
danielson frankly that that that they
can have is somebody to say hey here's
the big picture this is what's going on
and here's a long-term here's a 10-year
horizon there's a lot of money that's
just like okay I need to get an extra
turn
my fund I need to get it now and unless
it really is allocated toward something
that is clean tech or says look I want
something more than just a return so let
me kind of toss out another question
which is can you get a decent return in
the clean tech environment is is
investing its own virtue in this sector
I'm gonna jump in cuz I kind of have to
I want to comment a bit about sort of
this whole sustainability label on in
those of you that were in the room
yesterday and got a view of you know how
Blackstone looks at sustainability which
is they don't use that word they're
simply driving for efficiency in ROI I
get pretty nervous as we talk about
standardizing reporting for
sustainability and impact because I just
I think it drives strange behaviors
anytime accountants are driving business
decisions it's a bad day no offense to
the accountants in the room Oh same
comment as it relates to lawyers for
what it's worth it and so I'll give one
real example and so we've made an
investment in a machine learning
artificial intelligence company that by
most metrics no one would look at and
say oh that is an amazing sustainability
bet or an investment and yet when we
deployed it in a brownfield natural gas
application so across you know several
hundred wells we drove both the 20%
increase in efficiency and basically
output of the of the field but with a
seventy four percent reduction in
methane emissions that will trump
anything that we are towing in the sort
of you know sustainability feel-good
space out there a 74 percent reduction
in three months using artificial
intelligence and so that's the sort of
investment where we are expecting very
much a you know a sizable venture return
I will comment though when you start
looking at some of these longer lived
sort of hard tech to use that term this
sort of deals that that Damon was
talking about where it may take 18 years
well if you apply a discounted cash flow
to 25 you know a discount or a 25%
discount right well you better have a
you better be solving a massive massive
problem if that's if that's what you're
going after so you can do it but you
can't do it in the same way we did it in
2012 the way we tried to do it in 2007
and fail so I just I just want to jump
in a little bit just to clarify my point
on impact so let's say you have three
funds that are out in the market raising
money right they could put forward their
track record from a financial return
perspective but increasingly these funds
are going out there and also putting
forth metrics around impact you know
greenhouse gas emissions reduce jobs
created economic development you know a
variety of different metrics the
challenge is that right now there's no
objective way of assessing whether what
they're putting out there is true or not
so slowly you have three funds out there
approaching a limited partner at some
point the limited partners gonna say you
know I can't assess what's true what's
not and they're gonna step back right
and that's the danger I think of pulling
in some of the people off the sidelines
who might not be playing in this space
so well and I'll add to that because
I've seen situations where again being a
being a Carnegie Mellon kid I was taught
to sort of dig into the data just not
look at the headline and you dig into
the data on some of these bold claims
and you're sort of like wait a minute
timeout somebody once told me that that
stress can be defined as the difference
between expectations and reality and
sometimes to get money people give
artificially high expectations and then
if they don't deliver obviously
investors are gonna get stressed out and
there's a real danger because once you
lose your back and you're the
Neanderthal back in the cave going I'm
not going to go out there I might get
crushed again so you know it's an
interesting time but I think it's got to
be played correct
it's got to have good solid investment
and people that are actually making
prudent decisions so I'll add to that I
totally agree with the point that Marty
made and I think it's I think it's an
important one that's not talked about
much that some of these longer term time
horizon funds if there's an expectation
for a venture like returns even up over
a long time frame that's still really
hard to hit on an IRR basis but I think
it's important to tip to the to the root
of your question you know can there be
money you made or is virtue its own
reward I don't think it is its own root
word I don't think impact personally I
don't think impact can be achieved
unless big new companies are built that
achieve commercial success
so I think ultimately the only viable
pathways are one that are commercially
attractive to to commercial capital
where where we don't look for a return
for our capital when we place
philanthropic capital into companies but
we would never do it if we didn't think
that there was rent seeking capital
venture style capital ready and waiting
to take it over from us so that's kind
of how we try to square that circle okay
we're about a little bit halfway through
the session we want to leave a little
bit for for Q&A toward the end so I
don't want to me to be political but
just factual the recent change in
administration's in Washington how has
that changed your perspective on
investing in some of these sectors
okay well move on I'll jump in I moved
to Canada because I had concerns with
the u.s. political system I believe want
top of that Vancouver was a spectacular
place to live you know I I think we all
just about jumped off well I'll speak
for myself I I almost jumped off a cliff
two years ago or whatever it was for
fear that the world was going to end and
when we all stepped back you know a day
later the president actually does not
have as much power as any of us made
made here and we were my camp quite
pleasantly surprised with you know
additional funding for RPG and the like
and so I think our worst expectations
are proving to not be the case and you
know life goes on I will say though and
I will waive the Canadian flag living in
a country where we believe in science
we've put a price on carbon and we are
moving towards improved policy is
refreshing and in for the first time I'm
seeing a pretty significant migration of
talent north as opposed to just a
migration of talent into Silicon Valley
and that's whoever has that brain the
advantage on the intellect will win in
the long term and if US doesn't solve
some of this immigration I'm more
concerned about immigration than I am
about our climate policy right now if we
chase away talent we are in trouble as
you can speak in the United States and
what is Canada in the last six months
every day that the US tightens its
immigration canada open sis and that's
what i'm most fearful Thank You anyone
else anyway oh the Canada I think I
think we should just all look at deep
politicizing the word cleantech and
let's look at the economics of it and
what it means for the United States to
be a leader in these industries for the
betterment of everybody period okay this
November vote for them I'll add one or
two things in my perspective is a little
bit different and this one of the things
dealing with with tax credits which are
the currency and solar and wind and some
other different things right unique
clarification from the IRS because while
one side of the government says you
could do this they passed the law then
the IRS saw it says no no you have to do
it this way that way that way and you
got to stand on your head and something
else
making that out but but they need
compliance with existing you know
Treasury regulations so when I heard for
example well for every regulation that
we put in place we're gonna take two
away well there's these things called
Reb frocks and guidance and things like
that that the IRS has to give that
creates certainty for the industry to
make sure that they're doing things that
they know they're going to get the
credit and unfortunately and again I'm
not quite sure who why because I think
both sides blame each other there's some
positions particularly within a IRS that
that are unfilled since the last
administration well if the traffic cop
isn't there to tell you whether you can
go and the lights out it kind of makes
it a little bit difficult to figure out
whether you can kind of make a
right-hand turn go straight or anything
else so I'll add that is my perspective
it's a little bit different I think but
but aside from that I think the societal
issues are still there and people were
pushing and you could still make a
decent dollar from these kind of
investments
what about Berkeley how do people feel
in Berkeley oh boy
that's working I'm an employee at
Berkeley Lab indirectly report to Rick
Perry
but actually he visited the lab just
last week actually and unless he was
really putting on an act he was really
impressed with what we were doing there
and actually there's a great video of
him having a tug of war with one of our
one of our founders ray y de Kamp who's
developing a ultra strong 3d printable
resin repeating made at wishbone and
there's a cool video of them both trying
to break the wishbone
who won the competition I think Rick
Perry did and that was probably I'm not
sure but I suspect that was engineers so
let's let's kind of move on in
reason why sort of ask this question is
to get insight as to you know what
you've learned over time what was your
favorite energy investment as well as
one you thought would be world-class but
ended up not so much
describe what you learned I'll take a
crack at it
I'll let's tract the question a little
bit if that's okay um yes one learning
experience for me has been I I get
really interested in the technology and
the cost perspective and the business
model and all that and taking on taking
on the impact lens which for us is about
greenhouse gas emissions just realizing
how much how many new developments out
there are potentially very impactful or
sorry are potentially innovative and
could could make a good business but
might not move the needle in a big way
on greenhouse gas emissions and so one
of the things that we've developed
internally that Eric alluded to is a is
an internal way to to project out
forward-looking greenhouse gas emissions
and I've just I've learned that some of
the technologies that I get excited
about and think that they could be
really good businesses like say a
battery better battery separator
membrane or something like that really
compelling from a business perspective
actually doesn't have necessarily the
the climate impact that we might be
looking for so that's a lens that I'm
increasingly seeing filter things out
for us I'll jump in I will say and this
goes back to 2007 but we were the
largest shareholder in a company called
Solazyme which was one of the early
biofuels bio-oil splays in you know we
thought it was going to be fantastic we
went public a billion dollar valuation
and today it doesn't exist
and it doesn't exist because of the
shale revolution Frank
and I think that is a trend not to take
lightly obviously and when you think
about long-term price on natural gas the
other to think about is when
electrification of light vehicles takes
over and demand for oil drops now you're
gonna see oil become super cheap so if
you're a biofuels play trying to compete
with super cheap natural gas super cheap
oil good luck and so it's just a space
that I know a lot of people talk about
and are excited by I'm scared to death
of it and I don't know what it would
take to convince me to get back in on
the flip side what am I really excited
about I mentioned you know this this
investment we made in AI company I think
there are unbelievable opportunities for
AI in industrial applications that will
have a massive impact in terms of
efficiency and emissions in that space
the other one I'm really excited about
we've made an investment in this is
synthetic biology applications with new
gene editing tools within synthetic
biology are amazing and we're now
pointing those towards various
industrial applications I think there's
a lot of promise there Eric yeah so I
think a company that we're excited about
but also just really proud of the
founding team it's a company called new
mat technologies material sciences
material science IP out of Northwestern
but the company came together in
response to a Department of Energy
student business plan competition they
came together they won the competition
it gave them a little bit of a win in
their sales to take this IP and try to
build a company around it
and for a number of years they just cast
about and frankly they were they were
struggling because they couldn't find
you know the right beachhead market or
the right sort of application for this
you know metal organic frameworks
technology that they had developed and
then just through sheer perseverance
they finally zeroed in on an application
and sort of noxious industrial gases to
help storage of those gases that
basically you know you're
you know room pressure to you know
eliminate the need for compression and
so forth and also in the market just you
know opened up for them and they've been
just doing great they're now raising
their series be I think their valuation
you know is you know up you know forty
million dollars you know a few years ago
they were you know students coming out
Northwestern University so just really
proud of it but I think the lesson there
is the that are really identifying that
that that highly focused target market
to go after initially to sort get your
company on a good growth trajectory in
terms of I wouldn't just a company I'm
sort of I feel for is a company that has
an IOT platform for compressed air and
pneumatic systems for industrial
applications great technology but you
know what they've bumped up against and
what they're bumping up against it's
just how difficult it is to sell into
you know an industrial facility if your
product touches a production process
because you know the you know the plant
manager you know they don't want
anything disrupting their production
flows and they're not gonna take a new
piece of technology and let it touch you
know a mission-critical production line
and great technology they just haven't
been able to break through on the sales
side and I just I just feel for them
because you know great team great
technology but yeah just a really tough
market a real tough sales cycle can I go
off grip for one second no sort of
counsel for anyone any entrepreneurs in
the room I know no new Matt fairly well
and I think it's an incredible example
of you know moths are not sort of
household you know terms that everyone
knows there was an incredible technical
depth behind the company but in my
opinion where it really came to shine is
they've got a CEO that is amazing and
he's amazing at doing customer discovery
and for those of you that are trying to
build a company sitting in a lab you
don't learn anything sitting in the lab
you only learn stuff by getting in front
of potential customers and Ben has been
in I mean he is out there and when I sat
down first time he's like I talked to
one hundred and this vertical I talked
to under customer this well here's my
learnings here's and I was like
just blown away and so you you do not
have a company until you've talked to a
hundred customers and really really know
the pain point that you're going after
great example with you man okay I got to
give my quick example I appreciate that
actually it's gonna lead into the next
question on what advice you'd give an
entrepreneur but I'll give a shout out
to a company that won last year's you
know clean University prized the which
was robot me and it was like when you
see something that you say wow this
makes perfect sense an indoor vertical
farming as as Dave Danielson talked
about we're gonna have food issues we
have you know water issues we have
fertilizer runoff weight a wide variety
of different things and again they use
LED lights it's forty feet high they're
building they just finished their Series
a in the fall for twelve million dollars
and on the south side they're gonna be
making you know produce that's now
selling in Whole Foods but they're gonna
up that their production dramatically
they buy wind power for the LEDs and
they use robotics to keep the cost down
and to make it hyper efficient so when
it's ten degrees below zero outside in
Pittsburgh and January let's say they're
still gonna be just producing fresh
produce it also helps in the waste
because it's gonna be stead of trucking
it from the Salinas Valley several weeks
it actually shows up and a couple hours
later it's it's on the supermarket shelf
so it lasts longer so food waste and
creating things on one end of the
country shipping them to the point where
it only turns brown and no one buys it
doesn't make an awful lot of sense the
other thing I'll add is on the other
side of what doesn't work if there's
anything and particularly the larger the
capex the more consistent that margins
have to be over time I mean I've done
two I did design work on the Great
Plains coal gasification project in the
90s when we're recording with the Saudi
Arabia of coal how'd that work out
wasn't my investment but
sort of saw it that's consistent
throughout with energy and how you get
savings so but with that said let me
move on to our final question before we
turn it over to to everyone what advice
would you give to a scientist / or
entrepreneur in the audience who wanted
to start a company I was gonna say
cyclotron here I'd say keep your eyes
wide open be your own it's hard because
you have to be extremely optimistic but
extremely critical at the same time one
of the reasons why I really encourage
people to build their own technical
model is because you just need a
spreadsheet mix out and a few numbers
but because if you are the one if you're
the if you're the the technical person
you have much better insight into what
the potential of that technology is but
then building that spreadsheet model
allows you to then connect what you're
working on in the lab with whether or
not it actually moves the needle in the
marketplace and a lot of times that
they're totally disconnected a lot of
times the things that scientists want to
work on the sexy material or technology
has nothing to do with the actual cost
of the product or the facility it's it's
something more mundane like pH or the
type of metal you're going to use in the
in the processing plant that you need to
build right so I read or a buyer said
talk to people doing customer discovery
it's often uncomfortable for people
particularly were people who are you
know more comfortable working in the lab
to go out and talk to people but you'll
learn a lot but it's by talking to one
person and information that you'll never
be able to Google right or be able to to
capture in the lab anyone else just just
want to echo this get out of the lab get
uncomfortable I'm actually sitting in on
best techno economics course and working
really closely with one of the team's
that's going through it
and I see directly this this tension
between wanting to be precise and
correct and that how that prevents
technical founders in particular from
just guessing and have someone say no
that's wrong and this is the answer
that's what you want you want to get to
that point but you can't get to that
point until you get out of your comfort
zone so you know I think Marty called it
out the customer discovery is key one
one piece of advice that you know I just
it just always dumbfound to me that I
even have to articulate this but we see
it too often is just be honest be
truthful because it is is just I'm
always just surprised at how often you
know particularly young entrepreneurs
will step over the line will not
necessarily come forward with the full
truth about their product their
technology their you know their success
in the marketplace the truth you know
it's a small community
people talk it's amazing how you know
you know the truth we'll find find find
a light in just you look garner more
respect and gain more ground with
investors if you are aboveboard honest
and transparent about your business so I
know it
sorry I have to even say that yeah no I
I think that's actually correct I'll be
quick just one as other addition would
be find a partner and so particularly
for a technical founder find someone
with that business acumen that that can
really strengthen your weaknesses and if
you want to see what I think is the best
example of it opus 12 is a company we
invested in two brilliant technical
founders who are smart enough to then
partner up with ex McKinsey Stanford
Business School grad and then the three
of them went out and they're now just
crushing it but the two technical
founders on their own would have
ever done where they are today without
partnering with that that business
acumen so the friend of mine actually
uses the example of wildebeest and and
zebras and you might look at me like
what the heck you talking about the
Willoughby's can smell very well but it
can't see the zebra is the opposite so
the wildebeest smells the lion and you
always see them in in lines together
look at any picture and the one
identifies the Lions in the area the
other one goes where where okay there it
is in that sense when you have a
partnership right and same thing we have
great technical people maybe yes or no
as to the great business acumen often
not found in the same person but you
need somebody you can trust collaborate
with and bring your idea forward today
try add two cents too and just say that
from my own experience as well that
entrepreneurship is not sexy at all oh
come on it's not it's really not it's a
it's a it's a total grind and it's a
roller coaster one minute you're up
the next you're way down so you got her
love what you doing you you got to love
to win it it's not about the money it's
and I'll give a final piece of advice
whatever we know whatever the subject
matter is particularly technically
people love to show how much they know
and and talk about which electrons
moving where and whatever okay
I'm kind of the out alan alda school
where he said well you know describe
what fire is to a you know
twelve-year-old don't drag the people
into the weeds unless they say show me
or talk to me that the technology and
detail investors want to know at a high
level this makes sense there's
advantages to it there's economics to it
there's no competitor right now and then
they're gonna delve in and they'll hire
somebody probably to do the expertise to
tell
into the technology but it never spiit
ceases to amaze me how somebody wants to
drag me into the weeds and I don't want
to go got one or two minutes here one of
the exciting new tech tech areas you're
seeing and investing in today this could
be the last and final question I I'm not
gonna say blockchain so if you if you
say blockchain your your value just one
of four times but I agree with you
well deal I'm working on right now as an
energy storage with exactly the thesis
Davis was talking about earlier on long
strong steel so plus eight hour 12 hour
energy storage and she knows a bit about
the dough so yeah look how storage and
also I think Dave Dave did a great job
this morning laying out some of the most
important areas and we are we are as I
said before German by greenhouse gas
emissions reduction potential so we
don't have a sector okay a sector focus
or anything like that but that's that's
one area we're looking very deeply and
carefully at carbon capture as well as
we're interested in where we can have a
role in funding nuclear technologies as
well and where it's appropriate for
philanthropic capital to to fund
something at a small scale or if there's
a if there's a thesis there for us just
to name a few areas if somebody is
looking for four seed or pre seed
funding what's the best way to go about
getting it or who did doctor that just
came up as a question
I'd say apply to a cyclotron Road will
provide you runway seed funding access
to to a lab and time to figure out what
your product and market is before you
essentially get married to an investor
who might have different expectations
okay the wine forms right over here at
the reason - yeah I think applying to an
incubator or accelerator program
specifically that has a focus in this
area whether it be clean energy transfer
cyclotron Road or one of the other many
organizations that do a great job of
this
I think but but what you I think we want
to look for is a program team that has
deep knowledge in this area and has
hopefully some scars in this area so
they can again direct direct you along
the way for to avoid some of the
mistakes that happened the first time
around I have a personal goal at prime -
to see how long I can go before I tell a
company you're too early for us it
hasn't happened yet so we're willing to
go pretty early but we don't have a huge
pile of funding to send out so I would
love to say that a lot of we're hoping
to get to a place where there are a lot
of philanthropists who are willing to
support incredibly early seed stage
companies we're not quite there yet
we're working on it but I'm hopeful that
that's an area in the future that can
seat a lot more companies just grant
funding you know SBIRS RPE I mean work
every grant possibility for non diluted
funding I'll answer this one just
because I think this may be somebody
else knows differently or to incentivize
investing is there lobbying being done
to make capital gains on a clean tech
investment tax exempt we just went
through the major you know tax overhaul
it actually made it more difficult for
things with tax credits because
particularly corporates are now taxed at
21 percent versus 35 and I don't see any
new tax legislation that's going to
change anything and you got to get both
sides together to agree and that's
difficult in Washington so I think we've
reached our time limit Anna is that
correct she's given me the thumbs up I
don't know what that means continue or
you're done I think it means you're done
we're all going to thank Anna
who we have dubbed as a group the anti
entropy for those scientists in the room
ie she is one of the most organized
people that you ever want to be and we
think we think there may be uq3 yeah
give her a round of applause thank you
so much for inviting us
[Applause]